[Applaudissements]
elle deviendra trop savants bébé ça va
très bien fait pour ta vu qu'on a on a
beaucoup traité de médias juifs chiffres
et s'ils s'attendent s'attache à combler
mais dans les rangs jérémy savate à un
message on te demande de m'embrasser
oui on me dit de dire que j'ai la grippe
est gérée grippe non ces attaques et
ouais eh ben je vais passer un message
fort et un cap à la gastro ça va c'est
vrai je serai pas choper attendit la doc
gynéco qui veut nous parler oui bonsoir
une fille et décide à son ami imaginaire
voulez quoi l'histoire
non j avais rien c'est vrai un spasme
c'est vrai de quoi ça son halloween on
chauffe je voulais te dire un truc j'ai
oublié
[Applaudissements]
s'est passé exactement 11 secondes entre
le moment où il a levé la main au jeu
donnait à penser l'avenir n'était pas
important non ça va serrer mais tu t'en
rappelles ou pas du tout mon chéri tu
veux qu'on n'ose et c'était cet te
rappeler tu me dit que c'est bon tu les
as dame a donc attendu dix ans le temps
que tu lèves la magistrature démission
ou était ce cas c'est pas quelque chose
sur le média les bisous notable mais si
vous n'essayez pas de comprendre ce
qu'il dit c'est bon alors je dis il ya
eu deux chocolats guèye il lève encore
la main je viens vous aimez tout oui oui
c'est donc là il sert pas
[Applaudissements]
c'est reparti en est reparti c'est un
facilement battu nous dira alors merci
jeudi il ya eu deux chocolats gate 1
dans la grande race rae un an balances
ton post mais parce qu'il ya un enfant
le petit charlie qui vous a offert une
boîte de chocolats série dre et comme
thierry lhermitte dans le père noël est
une ordure
au moment où vous avez croqué le
chocolat vous allez tout il le regretter
peut-être extraordinaire alors
évidemment tout de suite c'est le zumba
mars dernier et tu promets trimestre de
l'année 2010 9 sélections jeunes là vous
vous dites le petit charlie me regarde
le chocolat et si monde
comment je m'en sortir social et bien
pour s'en sortir cyril hanouna se
transforme à nouveau en pipe oman ainsi
à chocolat à double double effet et
après j'ai bien qu'ils aient eu un couac
au chocolat soit la réponse était blanc
à l'intérieur des chocolats
alors on se calme chez moi aujourd'hui
[Rires]
je suis libre revient justement sur
l'acte cas du chocolat gates celui qui a
eu lieu à la fin de la grand drap sera
alors regarder une nouvelle raison pour
laquelle cyril zones à risque d'être élu
tard baba avis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fribourg prend un peu pour un blaireau
plus qu'un ami des flèches au sol pour
vous indiquer la sortie ça fait 3 heures
ou bosser ici vous faites tellement
démission ne savait même plus laquelle
vous avez présenté juste après
ces sept heures de direct
alors on a vu votre évasion
spectaculaire du plateau ça m'a rappelé
un peu l'évasion de tango et cash foyer
cm chose et alors il ya une image qui
extraordinaire mais furtif c'est quand
vous quittez les lieux en courant juste
après la détonation
regardez comme en syrie damas esquive
franchement c'est laure et de
l'animateur qui je suis comme un gamin
qu'appliquer des malabars de volanges
riz c'est pareil regardez bien à droite
qui va prendre ses jambes à son cou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il est temps d'évoquer la faim de
ballon reste en poste pour cette saison
alors j'avais envie qu'on voit les
moments qui ont fait que cette émission
allez nous manquer jusqu'en septembre
est de four kings se souvient pas de la
venue de marlène schiappa dans l'argent
mais elle est très proche du peuple donc
sur le plateau elle était très proche de
vous cyril duroueix c'est le laurier
d'animateurs qui adore ses invités mais
faut pas trop s'approcher quand même
merci d'être là en tout cas c'est
courageux de mokhtar de devenir voulez
vous asseoir peut-être ça va jusqu ici
pas bien ça très bien commencé
l'émission était très proche
33 cm mais votre charme avec marc lynch
a pas vous toucher beaucoup vous munir
et si vous allez vite vous couper la
parole et si les soupçons avaient m'a
ramené chez vous un rétablir en syrie
avant la proposition ça vous dérange at
il fait juste répondre sur deux points
on constate à votre regard vous étiez un
peu agacé quand vous pris par le bras
alors voilà on vous avait retrouvé une
heure après mais si je sais que c'était
les jantes une nourrice
ils ont également des tuteurs en france
la perrière qu'on sera dépendant des
partis d alors vous êtes quelqu'un de
très éclectique cyril vous pouvez dans
votre carrière de l'interview cima
charlize theron que gérer de koh lanta
charlie est célibataire vivant ils font
beaucoup
weepu charlize a les traits des requins
on l'a vu la semaine dernière
oui alors bref grâce à ballon ce ton
post avait interrogé jean marie le pen
aille chez lui et ce qui va nous manquer
plus et quand vous faites des interviews
de jean marie le pen juste pour réussir
à lui faire dire les mots d'art qu'aura
sera savez vous auriez pu devenir tenir
vingt ans je pense de chiens regardez
ra sera ou dar k ras sera ou dark à
nicolas sarkozy race raoudha retard et
dark à arcades dar kaoua sera donc la
jeanne d'arc a donc il émit d'arc amira
sera c'est un mot cedar trail un mot
pour définir nicolas sarkozy ce serait
quoi
non mais si on passera au dark à marca
sera carte à dar k donc jean marie le
pen ce que vous pouvez dire ils sont
d'arcadie plutôt sa dalle alors d'arc à
petit ça va dit oui mais il faut dire
d'arcachon barca je voulais pas le dire
dard kg bombay son parti et pour finir
c'est à dire bien sûr on voir le moment
que tout le monde attend évidemment
quand vous receviez un widget vous allez
au journal un homme tient mecs m'a
répété cette tête de petits fours de la
merde à reignac vous prenez vraiment
pour un gamin sans rigoler de croix sur
lézignan faire bien ils ne l'ont pas été
vraiment capable pour qu'on vienne alors
non mais cédric pas juste une question
posée en fait c'est fait quoi toute la
journée les trois premiers magnéto c'est
ce but c'est compliqué la donne je
l'écouté plus bas les quartiers au psg
ne s'est pas fait
mettant derrière à sa bouille arabe la
médaille de la troupe quoi râler on
n'est pas des gamins de magnéto sa
faveur alors quand vous recevez un
certaine il sait nilsen que la chance
d'être comédien combattants de mma est
mannequin et nissan a filmé de manière
très sérieuse être un grand séducteur
oui c'est vrai et logiquement vous avez
remporté le lauréat du gars qui n'est
pas convaincu par tout ce qu'on lui
raconte on est jeune on aime bien
séduire et ça c'est un gros défaut je
suis la con séducteur
[Musique]
j'ai été moi votre sofa lâché chaque
regard des cartes soient débattues allez
pour finir quand je regarde tout ce
n'est pas des plus hauts salaires
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai aller qu'en
vouloir touche pas à mon poste je
remarque il ya quelquefois des
chroniqueurs fictive les chroniqueurs
qui passe l'émission est quasiment rien
dire oui c'est vrai ils sont quand même
payer donc ça c'est le meilleur plan du
monde
alors comme je suis un homme de
statistiques j'ai décidé de faire les
comptes ah ouais j'ai pris toutes les
émissions de la semaine dernière et j'ai
compté voilà un beau parleur plus
acérées bord ça a beaucoup parlé qui a
peu parlé la semaine dernière qu'il est
temps de découvrir le classement avec
n'oubliez pas de prendre la parole
bas du classement avec 70 interventions
la semaine dernière celui qui prend la
parole surtout quand on lui demande rien
matthieu delormeau séquelles et lille
qui attaqua des meccanos faut l'avoir
dans l'os
juste derrière avec 48 at invention dont
47 fayotage jean-michel mais en
championnat canadien tokyo a de la
gueule
[Musique]
on passe au haut du classement avec à la
deuxième place
celui qui oublie souvent de prendre la
parole puisqu'il n'a parlé que 17 x 17
comme le nombre de ces enfants dont
janet castaldi et cette semaine le
numéro 1 de ce classement ne n'oubliez
pas de prendre la parole et maxime gagné
avec seulement quatorze interventions il
suit un peu trop les conseils de gilles
verdez
[Applaudissements]